Dr Umar man give me my 500 back man tell
the story tell the story of the 500. so
I have the series called giving
strangers the inward pass and uh I have
three volumes
so let's let's play that today
well I mean you guys already got it and
um I was like damn it'll be hilarious to
get Dr Umar to like react to it and just
get his reaction you know it's like this
is a level three this is a level
three this is everything yeah and
um so you to get an interview from him
you have to like donate 500 to a school
yeah so I PayPal him and everything
we're we're emailing to set it up and
then he just ghosts me and I'm like yo
Dr Umar or Dr Umar like you're really
gonna do this to a brother and so I was
like damn you know what I was like I
might as well just troll him so he was
in Jacksonville so he flew to
Jacksonville I got a dashiki and we sit
through this whole seminar it's a show
he's up there doing like bits right and
you posted like
five minutes of the seminar but I'm not
gonna lie he was looking spinning like
yeah
Brody's funny but he'd be spinning
sometimes and uh halfway through I was
like because I really didn't know what I
thought I was just gonna confront him
but then I was like damn it'll be funny
if like I show him my like white
girlfriend so that's one of my friends I
was like yo send me a picture of you
that you look the whitest in
and she sent it to me and so whenever I
went up I was like yo Dr Umar this is my
girl and he's like oh he's a snow bunny
lover get him out of here and like just
trolling him but Dr Umar please give me
my 500 back I want to do a video where I
went to one of his seminars and I bring
like 100 white people and just like have
us all sit and just listen but into
cheeky oh that'll be a joke is he
crushing
like does it feel like stand up when
you're watching him oh bro he's
hilarious yeah but the thing is though
it's like he's not trying to be funny
yeah he's just uh he's just talking like
uh my fans they were just in his IG
Lodge just saying give Junior his 500
back he's like we got grown men in here
on julion's next side get off Gideon's
nutsack
when people be on my ass on Twitter I
just you get that sound bite and I just
put it under their thing yeah I think
you got your 500 worth yeah
you got a sound bite but it's a
principle you know it's a principle